>>> FELLAS, WHAT ARE WE UP TO
TONIGHT?
YOU GUYS COMING OVER, PLAYING
TONY HAWK?
>> I'M BUSY TONIGHT.
>> I'M TIRED TONIGHT.
>> YOU'RE BUSY AND YOU'RE TIRED?
>> MAYBE TOMORROW.
>> OH, YEAH.
COOL.
NO SWEAT.
NEXT TIME.
>> HEY, MAN.
EVERYBODY OKAY WITH YOU AND YOUR
LITTLE FRIENDS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M KIND OF WORRIED THEY'RE
HANGING OUT WITHOUT ME.
>> DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD MAYBE
FOLLOW THEM, FIND OUT?
>> FOLLOW THEM?
YOU DON'T MEAN A --
>> YEAH.
A STAKEOUT.
>> WHAT ARE THEY DOING OUT HERE
IN THE SUBURBS?
WHO'S HOUSE IS THIS?
WOW, DUDE.
I'M GOING TO TEXT THEM.
>> WHO'S THAT?
>> BEN.
>> DID HE JUST THROW HIS PHONE
AWAY?
>> THAT'S A LOW BLOW, MAN.
WELL, TIME TO GO IN THERE AND
KILL THEM?
>> NO, MAN.
WHAT?
>> WE'LL MAKE IT LOOK LIKE A
ROBBERY.
>> JESUS, DUDE.
THAT'S NOT WHY WE'RE HERE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY THEY BAILED ON ME.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THEM?
THEY LOOK REALLY COZY.
>> THIS IS REALLY NICE.
>> ARE THEY TOGETHER?
>> WHAT?
>> WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
SHOULD WE HEAD OUT?
>> WE'RE NOT DONE, MAN.
OH, MY GOD.
>> THEY'VE GOT A BABY TOO.
KIDS, DINO NUGGETS ARE READY.
>> THEY HAVE A FAMILY?
>> UH-OH, AND ONE MOODY TEEN.
>> DINO NUGGETS AGAIN?
>> OKAY, MISTER, I WORKED VERY
HARD.
>> HONEY, RADICAL ACCEPTANCE.
>> THIS IS INSANE.
>> IT'S 2015.
IT'S NOT INSANE TO BE GAY.
>> IT'S NOT 2015, MAN.
AND I'M NOT MAD THEY'RE GAY.
I'M MAD ABOUT THIS SECRET
BEAUTIFUL LIFE THEY NEVER TOLD
ME ABOUT.
>> MAYBE THEY'RE SCARED TO TELL
ANYONE.
>> KIDS, UNCLE KENAN IS HERE.
>> I'M GOING TO TEXT HIM BECAUSE
KENAN WOULDN'T LIE TO ME.
THEY CAN'T JUST KEEP THROWING
THEIR PHONES AWAY.
>> YOU NEVER SAW ANY SIGNS OF
THIS IN THE PAST?
>> NOT THAT I REMEMBER.
WE WOULD ALWAYS JUST HANG OUT
AND LAUGH TOGETHER.
MAYBE THEY WERE JUST AFRAID TO
TELL ME BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID
TO HURT ME.
THEY CAN'T RISK LOSING ME
BECAUSE THEY LOVE ME TOO MUCH.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
>> WHERE DID THEY EVEN GET THAT?
>> COME ON, KIDS.
TIME FOR BED.
WE GOT WORK TO DO.
>> WHAT WORK?
>> LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE DOING
AUDITIONS TO REPLACE YOU.
>> ALEC READING FOR BEN
MARSHALL.
>> I'M GOING IN THERE.
>> AND SATURDAYS, YOU'RE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE --
>> BEN --
>> IT'S NOT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> THEN TELL ME WHAT IT IS.
>> JOHN AND I HAVE A SECRET
FAMILY, AND WE'RE HOLDING
AUDITIONS TO REPLACE YOU.
>> THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT IT WAS.
THIS IS INSANE, MAN.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, MAN.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE SHOULDN'T BE HOLDING
AUDITIONS TO REPLACE HIM BECAUSE
THERE'S ONLY ONE YOU.
>> AND YOU ARE IRREPLACEABLE.
RIGHT, BEN?
>> THANKS, GUYS.
BAD BOYS FOR LIFE.
MAN, I FEEL LIKE WE'RE BACK AT
NYU.
>> OH, MY GOD, DUDE.
SO MUCH BETTER THAN BEN.
>> HE'S THE PERFECT REPLACEMENT.